day after day of revolting revelations
in court isn't making either johnny depp
or amber heard any more popular they're
sending a lot of attention they craved
for their toxic relationship amber heard
his understanding this week and giving
what some think is the performance of
her life others think she's a real
victim
we're in the bedroom this whole time but
up against the wall of the cabin
and slams me up by my neck
and holds me there for a second and
tells me that he
he could kill me
i felt so embarrassed that he could kick
me to the ground
in front of people
and be more embarrassing i didn't know
what to do about it he's howling
like
like an animal
while holding the dog out of the window
everyone just froze
he
proceeds to do a cavity search
well tv host tommy lehrer joins me now
tommy i
i just don't know what to make of this
gate other than i seem to spend half my
life listening to these two in
courtrooms slagging each other off and
making vile accusations about each other
i don't know who to believe i don't know
how much of it is true they're two
actors what do you think
well you nailed it we've got two actors
so we're going to get a performance of a
lifetime probably from both of them but
i got to tell you this it makes sense to
me that amber heard is of aquaman fame
because everything is seeming a little
fishy here but i'll tell you pierce what
really bothers me most about all of this
is that we learned this week that the
aclu they were actually the ones that
drafted the op-ed for the washington
post in the first place and they wanted
to time the release of the op-ed to the
aquaman press tour so all of this seems
fishy all of this seems very
performative here i'm sure that they had
a very toxic relationship but in the
court of public opinion i would say
amber heard is not making out too well i
mean i to be fair i don't think he is
either and i think that they're trashing
each other's reputations so badly that
whoever ends up winning the damage is
kind of done in the court of public
opinion like you say reputationally i
think they're basically talking
themselves into being unemployable
aren't they
you would think so but i do think that
at the end of the day johnny depp is
looking a little better here i think
amber hurt is talking herself in circles
now i'm not saying that she didn't
experience horrible things i think he
probably did as well it seems like a
very toxic disgusting relationship but
we start hearing about how they wanted
to time the release of this talking
about domestic violence the aclu's
involvement in all of this it seems like
she was looking to get a lot of
attention off of his name and that all
just reads very cheap to me especially
when we're talking about something as
crucial and important as domestic
violence not something to time to movie
press yeah i mean i just i don't know i
don't know how this all washes up but i
just it's almost unlistenable you listen
to the details are slowly getting down
to seven fingers and feces in bed and
stuff it's like please just pass the
sink bucket i can't hear any more of it
yeah i think at the end of the day too
amber heard it's gonna be really hard
for her to recover from all of this you
know once you talk about feces in the
bed
i know that johnny depp got kind of a
good laugh at that though he certainly
wasn't trying to on the stand it's going
to make it very difficult for both of
them but like i said in the court of
public opinion i think amber heard is
playing a far worse at least in the
perception of those watching we'll have
to wait and see though it's not over and
we'll probably still be talking about it
next week and there will be another
court case next year we have to put up
with this all over again all right
before i let you go tomorrow i want to
play your little clip this is doing the
rounds on tick tock i want to get your
reaction as an american woman to what
this well all we know is she's a latina
living in boston that's her description
of herself and she posted this
men who look at the bill too long are
broke if i'm on a date and the guy
reaches to pick up the check and doesn't
immediately look over the bill quickly
put his card in and call it a day
i will think that he isn't used to
picking up the check regularly on a date
which will make me think that he
actually can't afford it and has no
money which means he cannot afford me
i'm sorry i find that so despicable
and
money digging and all the rest of it
can you try and defend it at all there's
another american woman
listen she's not wrong from my
experience if she doesn't look at the
bill for too long it probably means
listen i think just from experience it's
this now i think that she might be a
little money hungry here she might be
looking to get a free meal so that's you
know her and her personal life and
whatever she does on a date but i will
tell you this it comes across very beta
male to me when somebody asks a girl a
woman out on a date and then doesn't
necessarily want to pay for it listen
it's going to cost me a lot of money to
get my hair and my makeup my outfit the
least you can do is pick up dinner
my golden rule i think that's a very
alpha male thing well i would say
throughout my adult life i've always
paid uh for dinner for with another
woman however i've always remembered the
names of the women who never offered to
to go hearts i would never let them but
i'll never forget the ones who never
even offered tommy i've got to leave it
there lovely to talk to you come back
soon
thanks so much